l'eau
laurent et et bien merde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça va très bien énorme buzz la semaine
dernière énorme et non quand yann moix
chez sur les flics on a pris deux cent
mille auditeurs énorme mais on n'est pas
encore au million donc je vais essayer
de te filer un petit coup de main dans
le même esprit que yann jours à dire que
les profs sont tous des feignants qui ne
pensent qu'aux vacances c'est scandaleux
les infirmières sont jamais là quand on
les appelle oui jamais un peuple eh oui
oui c'est ça comme ça les employés de
mairie sont des branleurs
des vrais branleur tu peux passer trente
ans sans rien [ __ ] et les éboueurs
sont d ordinaire si on ne fait pas ça
veut pas le million avec ça je vais être
fondus pour les pouilles
[Musique]
servisair
mission qui nous permet de savoir quel
jour on est en compagnie de mon ami
laurent nature
et tout de suite j'accueille yann moix
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ryan bien lors des finales des news
cette semaine en répétant évidemment le
titre du livre de mes invités frédéric
ploquin journalistes et maggie biskupski
policière le bouquin s'appelle la peur a
changé de camp et vous vous l'avez dit
d'une façon un petit peu plus grossières
je les traduis en argot mais peut-être
qu'il fallut que je m'exprime as avec
plus de soin c'est sûr l'imparfait du
subjonctif ça sent la garde à vue
non ce que j'aurais dû dire ce que juste
dû dire la semaine dernière c'est que la
police a est un phénomène ou un monstre
bicéphale et schizophrène d'un côté les
conditions de travail et on le sait on
le sait tous peut-être qu'il fallait
rappeler ce postulat sont épouvantables
il manque de moyens il manque de soutien
il manque d'appui et il manque parfois
de parole politique ferme et clair donc
d'un côté ils sont pris dans cette dans
ce piège-là et un autre piège dans
lequel ils sont pris c'est celui de
certaines violences policières auquel
j'ai été moi même témoin est confronté
et peut-être que j'ai voulu ce jour-là
exprimée par la colère une impuissance
pour un message que je n'arrive pas à
faire passer depuis des mois et des mois
qui est que j'ai vu de mes yeux vu
indépendamment de tout les bon flic de
france et ils sont nombreux les
tabassages et les gazages que j'ai vu
faire subir à des jeunes migrants oui
mais ça c'est vrai que c'est un
traumatisme qui reste est prégnant chez
moi et ça peut-être déformé ma grille de
lecture de la réalité général
non mais je suis officier un gilet pare
balles pour moi accès en gilets
pare-balles je suis officier de l'armée
française et j'ai été officier de
gendarmerie de réserve donc ce serait un
peu caricatural que de me réduit ralenti
flic isme je ne suis pas des ailes cohn
bendit et nous ne sommes pas en 1968 non
très bien ce traité et maintenant c'est
l'heure des récompenses qui peuvent
faire mal c'est l'heure des moines d'or
[Musique]
le premier c'est pour claude schopp donc
le tableau de courbet en fait c'est
l'origine du monde c'est une question
très grave ça a l'air tout bête on a
retrouvé le visage de la femme qui était
à l'origine du monde c'est à dire que
finalement un tableau qui représente est
universellement toutes les femmes est
devenue une seule si vous voulez
l'équivalent je veux donner une image
que tous les téléspectateurs vont
comprendre imaginez qu'on fasse la même
chose avec l'âge la joconde qu'on montre
le pubis de la joconde celle inverse ces
processus inverse tout le monde serait
choqué là qu'on montre le visage d'un
pubis c'est aussi choquant c'est comme
si on montrait le visage de dieu et
surtout on vit dans une société j'ai lu
une phrase qui m'a révulsé je vais vous
la cité l'un des plus grands mystères du
monde des arts et sans doute résolu on
vit dans une société post moderne dont
l'obsession est de résoudre des mystères
ce qu'on aime dans dieu dans la religion
dans l'art c'est précisément que ça veut
dévoiler une vérité donc l'art est là
pour dévoiler une vérité il faut que
l'art reste voilé la vérité ne doit pas
dévoiler l'art et pour conclure je
dirais que d'une certaine manière c'est
comme si on souhaitait prolonger une
toile de renoir ou un ciel bleu par une
obscène photos de yann arthus-bertrand
très bien
c'est un peu comme si on dévoilait
l'identité du soldat inconnu aussi voilà
exactement est la conséquence que j'aime
bien
or le deuxième c'est pour google google
fête ses 20 ans et je donnerai le mois
que dure du totalitarisme soft à google
ça fait 20 ans que finalement nous
sommes privés d'une certaine manière de
deux libertés une poignée d'individus
quelques copains ça sonne l'intelligence
humaine
formate les consciences mondiale en nous
présentant des interfaces desquels nous
sommes prisonniers nous allons de choix
préétabli en choix préétabli en nous
faisant accroire à nous mêmes que nous
sommes libres et finalement nous sommes
exactement semblable au minotaure et
dans le labyrinthe demandé par minos et
fabriqué par des dalles minos c'est le
marché c'est le profit et des dalles
c'est google et nous sommes prisonniers
de quelque chose c'est de cette prison
qu'est devenu le temps google nous
arrache du temps de vie nous arrache du
temps de vécu et nous arrache du temps
humain
tout le temps que nous passons sur ces
interfaces qui nous font aller de
branche en branche est finalement déduit
de notre existence c'est déduit notre
passage sur terre et nous sommes là pris
dans un étau où finalement le temps
n'existe plus abolie et nous passent
entre les mains sans avoir été vécue moi
je suis là
mais il n'ya pas que des mythes
chronophage car le grand midas peut
changer pour en 30 minutes
là c'était minos avant troisième moix
d'or benalla roi du sel fut alors les
histoires de beda là me fascine
admettons que benalla n'ai rien fait de
mal on peut pas dire non plus qu'il ait
fait quelque chose de bien vous êtes
d'accord donc oublions benalla cinq
minutes c'est à dire que le selphy
ignore la notion de bien et de mal c'est
à dire que on sert 1930 des gens
voudraient faire en soi même en 1945 des
gens voudraient faire des scènes fille
avec hitler tout comme bon pour faire
des séries avec gandhi dans la même
journée à rome des gens voudront faire
un selphy etc le pape avec rocco
siffredi dans la même journée et le cmfi
a ceci de particulier donc il abolit le
bien et le mal mais il est une autre
particularité on accepte du moment
qu'ils soient connus la proximité avec
n'importe qui mais ça va dans l'autre
sens la star qui est prise en otage du
cmfi lui aussi il pose avec quelqu'un
qui ne connaît pas c'est à dire il peut
lui-même posé avec un serial killer avec
un violeur ou un assassin d'enfants sans
problème est donc là il ya un truc bij
ectif qui donnent le vertige et je
rajouterais quand même une chose c'est
que la véritable star c'est pas la
célébrité dans le sel fille de l'après
du point de vue géographique celui qui
fait le sel fille il est devant la
célébrité est donc en fait la célébrité
devient le décor de lego et on vit dans
une société qui n'est plus apte et on
n'est plus dans l'athéisme on aime plus
dans lego théisme on est dans l'auto
théisme chacun ait son propre dieu et
ils croient lui-même toute la journée et
la réalité sont des corps y compris
quand la réalité et la plus grande
célébrité mondiale
le dernier schéma grands champions de la
terre alors macron a dit mec à en
planète great game 7 en sorte que
l'applet redeviennent grande et il a été
élu pour cela champion du monde de
l'environnement il a reçu un titre
officiel qu'il y vaut maintenant toutes
les médailles du monde alors et je
dirais que c'est exactement la même
chose que s'ils avaient eu la médaille
de la croix rouge pour son action envers
les migrants par exemple il y avait le
prix d'éloquence pour son histoire de
traverse âge de rue ou s'il avait la
médaille de la résistance parce qu'il a
dit qu'il vienne me chercher c'est à peu
près de ce niveau là dans un pays où on
a interdit l'interdiction du glyphosate
dans un pays où le seul type crédible
nicolas hulot a quand même démissionné
parce qu'on ne fait rien pour la planète
et dans un pays on a augmenté la
consommation d'énergie fossile de 4% en
un an et malgré tout il est champion
alors on fait ce qu'on pourrait dire de
macron c'est qu'il est surtout le
séguéla de l'environnement il a eu une
formule génial comme séguéla avait
inventé par exemple la force tranquille
en 988 cc le champion du slogan de la
formule et de la formulation et non pas
de l'environnement et je vais vous dire
si macron avait dit tiens et si eux
étaient légèrement différent de mc2i
l'aurait prix nobel de physique bravo
la semaine prochaine
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant c'est l'heure du débat de
la semaine c'est la battle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
or la battle le débat haut débit avec ce
soir eugénie bastié
raphaël reynes houleux et constance
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
eugénie bastié bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
et vous publié aux éditions du cerf le
port émissaire bienvenue parmi nous
le mouchoir
important d'objets l'économie et vous
publiez du 6 était le féminisme
schaeffer's bienvenue parmi nous et
qu'on sent le comédien et humoriste
chroniqueuse dans l'émission par jupiter
sur france inter et sur la scène du
théâtre des deux ânes avec votre nouveau
spectacle intitulé pot pourri à partir
du 9 octobre bienvenue dans meetic
[Applaudissements]
un an après mythe ou révolution
féministe ou chasse à l'homme occidental
mais d'abord l'édito de blake au magnéto
serge
à la suite de l'affairé ben stein
dimanche 15 octobre 2017 à 16h21
l'actrice alyssa milano publiait le
tweet qui allait lancer le mouvement
mitu vous aussi vous avez été harcelés
ou agresser envoyé mitu en réponse à ce
tweet son appel est repris cinq cent
mille fois sur twitter en seulement 24
heures et le slogan mis tout est adoptée
par 5 millions de personnes sur facebook
un an plus tard la déflagration initiale
a produit une onde de choc tous le monde
entier
dorénavant je crois que c'est clair pour
tout le monde les producteurs n'ont plus
le droit de violer les actrices
est par contre il ya quelque chose qui
n'est pas clair c est ce que nous on a
encore le droit de coucher pour avoir
les rôles comme tous les grands
mouvements progressistes qui veulent
changer le monde me tous voudraient
divisé l'humanité en deux sous la
révolution on opposait la noblesse au
tiers état sous le front populaire on
opposait les riches et les pauvres en
mai 68 on opposait les jeunes gouvieux
et bien me to a décidé d'opposer hommes
et les femmes
la distribution des rôles est limpide
d'un côté les femmes qui me sens ultime
de l'atalante masculine
et de l'autre les hommes des souvenirs
banc des accusés
[Applaudissements]
aux états unis ça ne rigole pas des
stars sont déchus des pdg en
démissionner et cette semaine c'est
carrément le candidat de trump à la cour
suprême qui est mise en cause
en france la campagne adoptez un slogan
bon coup plus violent
est-ce que balances ton port sonnait
comme un appel à la délation et à la
vengeance
sauf que dans les faits la plupart des
hommes accusés publiquement comme
darmanin hulot ou depardieu ont surmonté
l'épreuve en france le puritanisme anglo
saxons passe moins bien votre plus
grande actrice oui je suis catherine
deneuve a d'ailleurs signé une pétition
pour défendre le droit des hommes à
importuner les femmes pour les séduire
réfléchissez pauvre catherine elle n'a
pas les reprendre la loi a changé la
semaine dernière un gars complètement
bourré amine main aux fesses à une jeune
femme en la traitant de grosse [ __ ] et
bien pour la première fois en france
il a été condamné à 300 euros d'amendé
pour outrage sexistes et oui les hommes
vont désormais devoir être un peu plus
subtil pour draguer les femmes
et
voilà c'est jason blake aux mises en
images de julia gras bravo blaco bravo
julien alors j'ai mis vous dites que le
mot d'ordre mis tous invité les victimes
à se délivrer alors que balance son port
finalement est une invitation à la
délation public oui forcément mon livre
n'est pas un livre antimite ou c'est
plutôt un livre anti balances ton port
et ce qui m'a gêné en ce mouvement ce
n'est pas la libération de la parole des
femmes qui me semble une bonne chose
mais c'est la question de libre de
substituer cette libération de la parole
à ces états de droit et finalement au
procès en bonne et due forme ce qu'a
montré mis tout c'est qu'il y en avait
un système judiciaire qui en effet été
inefficace puisque en effet beaucoup de
femmes n'osent pas porter plainte au
loup quand elle portait plainte leur
agresseur n'était pas condamné la
question c'est est ce que parce que ce
système est inefficace on doit le
remplacer par un tribunal public par le
lynchage et par finalement le name and
shame il y avait quelque chose presse de
de cathartique né dans l'utilisation de
ce sigle des arrivées une balance c'est
à dire l'injonction à délation tonton
port c'est à dire sous-entendu toute
femme un port en réserve a balancé et
port vraiment quel animal méprisée dans
deux monothéisme et qui est vraiment
l'animal voilà affreux par excellence et
donc il ya presque une dimension
religieuse danser dans ce mot d'ordre
alors concernant balance tranports vous
parlez de torrents victimaire un déluge
charriant les bons sentiments et les
règlements de compte oui je trouve que
ce mouvement a tout emporté à tous mis
dans le même sac de la remarque sexiste
dans l'ascenseur à la main sur les
fesses jusqu'au viol et jusqu'au crime
et on met tout sur le dans le même sac
alors que je moi je suis pour la
hiérarchisation des souffrances et je
trouve que à tout mettre dans le même
panier au nom de lutter contre une
prétendue culture du viol qui je pense
est un est un est une construction est
un fantasme je trouve que c'est
dangereux parce que on donne le
sentiment et enfin l'idée que l'occident
ce serait un enfer pour les femmes alors
que je suis désolé ce n'est pas pour
rien que c'est que me touche justement a
surgi en occident c'est parce que les
femmes sont déjà libres qu'elles peuvent
prendre la parole pouvoir dénoncer leur
agresseur
honnête oui alors vous dites nous dit
toujours il faut pas essentialiser
faux-pas essentialiser les musulmans par
exemple les musulmans mais en fait on
essentialise les hommes j'ai une espèce
d'entité diaboliser quoi oui c'est un
peu le paradoxe ce sont les mêmes qui
disent pas d' amalgame lorsqu'on parle
par exemple des minorités des personnes
issues de l'immigration là se sont
permis de faire des amalgames absolument
honteux on a vu les on a vu des
féministes dire par exemple que un voire
deux hommes sur trois étaient des
agresseurs et on a l'impression qu'on
essentialise l'homme justement il ya
deuxième paradoxe est que en fait on
nous répète à longueur de journée qu'il
n'ya pas de différence entre les hommes
et les femmes que les hommes et les
femmes c'est la même chose mais pourtant
bizarrement il ya que des ports il n'y a
pas de truies par exemple cette balance
détruit alors vous dites la libération
du désir a tué le désire on est passé de
jouir sans entraves à la chasse à
l'agresseur serre que mai 68 en fête a
été rattrapé par le politiquement
correct venue des états unis oui c'est
ce que dit
très bien jean claude michéa il dit
quand la tyrannie du politiquement
correct se retourne contre la tyrannie
du plaisir on assiste au spectacle
étrange de mai-68 portant plainte contre
mai 68 c'est ça exagéré quand on est
dans un système complètement paradoxal
c'est à dire à la fin dans une société
qui ne parlent que de sexualité à
longueur de journée qui exhibe la
sexualité qui l injonction la jouissance
partout très jeune et en même temps une
société qui punit qui contrôle qui qui
surveille le désir en permanence alors
rafael vous publiez avec margot collet
chez first beyond ci était le féministe
alors pourquoi beyond ci parce que en
2014 aux mtv video music awards c'est la
dcri féministe en gros derrière elle
alors la morale du livre donc c'est le
féminisme n'a jamais tué personne le
machisme tue tous les jours qu est une
phrase de la grande benoîte groult vous
réagissez comme en eau aux propos et au
livre de deux génies bastien à une
opposition sur presque tous les points
mais on on le sait on sait qu'on a des
idéologies pour le coup différente des
manières d'analyser la société
totalement différente il ya peut-être un
point sur lequel je vous rejoins c'est
l'essentialisation et l'animalisation ou
en effet le balances ton port osez le
féminisme n'était pas à l'origine du
hashtag et on trouve qu'au contraire le
mouvement est un mouvement de libération
de l'écouté de la parole des femmes et
sur le paradoxe que vous évoquez sur
notre revendication en tant que
féministe à l'égalité notre analyse
qu'il n'ya pas de différence essentielle
entre les femmes et les hommes et ce
paradoxe d'aujourd'hui d'avoir des
femmes victimes de violence masculine
c'est le paradoxe de la réalité de ce
que nous on appelle le patriarcat de
siècle de construction sociale vont nous
a appris en tant que filles et garçons
en tant que femmes et hommes à nous
comporter différemment c'est bien cela
qui crée les violences et qu'on essaye
aujourd'hui de remettre en cause moi je
crois que le patriarcat n'existe plus la
domination masculine a été déconstruite
pourquoi parce que qu'est-ce que le
patriarcat il reposait sur
l'institutionnalisation de la de
l'autorité masculine il n'existe plus
dans le droit et sur la maîtrise de la
fécondité des femmes qui n'existe plus
puisque les arts et les femmes ont la
maîtrise leur fécondité donc ce
patriarcat ainsi sûr et il n'existe plus
en tout cas l'institutionnalisation de
la domination masculine elle n'existe
plus
exister en tout cas jamais vraiment dont
les textes par exemple ça a toujours été
une instit une fille de 6 ans faux et la
plupart du temps c'était par exemple
parce qu'on pense l'universel comme
quelque chose de masculin on est quand
même sur une méthode de partage du
pouvoir qui soit symbolique sociale
économique qui se fait à l'avantagé des
hommes c'est ça que nous sommes en train
de remettre en cause et finalement on
reconstruit une société qui implique ses
deux moitiés bien alors qu'en jetant jeu
le 28 août vous faites une chronique sur
france inter sur le thème des chats une
chronique que vous finissez top9 le
thème de la chronique c'était la journée
mondiale du topless voilà et j'ai pas
juste montrer mes seins pour montrer mes
seins c'était un geste et pour allier le
fond à la forme ça a fait tout un de
teint fois parce que j'ai commencé à me
faire insulter on m'a dit que c'était
une grosse [ __ ] tous à des trucs que
j'ai pas voir des trucs assez terrible
et
ça m'a libéré tôt n'est donc pas ce que
je pensais faire chier quelques vieux
con mais je pensais pas qu'il reste et
autant de gens hyper point c'est que
tout est calé se sentir agressé par deux
tétons parce que quand même s'ils n'ont
pas tous sur le web la voilà sur la
plage les femmes soient en culotte tous
les états y croise ses terres
revendiquer la liberté de son corps de
vouloir dire bah ouais je suis si j'ai
envie de me mettre nue de montrer ma
vraie traîné regard des voisins magnéto
vouloir faire la nique à tous ces
puritains moralisateurs qui nous disent
qu'on est pervers avec notre peau con
air alors que eux ils ont juste un
problème avec leur zizi
venez on n'a qu'à monter
[Rires]
tout faire tout seul vous savez
j'ai une idée on prédit je n'ai rien qui
est en fait en relève on aurait une
technique on le ferait glisser avec mme
millette et une fois et pas dans les
étouffe rec moche comme ça qu'ils
auraient tué par des gros bonnets
d'abord en présentant non c'est bien ce
que je trouve choquant quand on fait ce
genre de séquences le minimum pour les
spectateurs c'est d'apprendre son texte
par coeur et de pas voir les fiches
devant les nichons quoi quand même un
respect pour le voyeurisme
j'ai l'impression parfois on confond
dans ce débat la symétrie et l'égalité
ouais il n'y a pas de symétrie entre les
hommes et les femmes en revanche
légalité tout à fait possible on a tous
une sexualité est écoulé cette sexualité
dans la rue dans la vie dans les jours
c'est la chose la plus difficile au
monde et moi je pense que depuis des
milliers d'années des centaines d'années
les hommes ont écoulé leur sexualité au
détriment des femmes et là on a une
chance historique c'est que ça ce n'est
plus jamais lieu s'il faut en passer par
une phase d' exagération ça ne dérange
pas et c'est d'ailleurs parce que
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
est à deux doigts de se faire enfin qu'
il ya ce dernier bastion qui se met à
craquer et qui parfois peut avoir des
travers pas des travers de porc des
travers tout court et peut-être que
c'est sain de manière provisoire que
cette exagération ait lieu et je
rajouterais d'ailleurs que les hommes
sentent que ça commence à craquer parce
que le seul domaine où leur sexualité
fantasmer celle en fait qui assujettit
les femmes continuent à dominer ce sont
sur les sites pornographiques qui
explosent et c'est parce que ils sont en
train de perdre ce combat enfin que la
pornographie a pris des proportions
qu'elle n'avait jamais pris jusqu'à
maintenant je citerai deux de ce point
de vue là à 100% du côté des femmes
justement pour avoir la chance
historique de les découvrir enfin j'ai
dû prendre des heures
[Applaudissements]
la formule 1 plus intéressant parce
qu'en effet aujourd'hui la pornographie
explose et je trouve que l'on fait très
peu dans les points publics seront très
peu pour lutter contre ce fléau
notamment auprès des plus jeunes parce
que en effet on n'avait pas raconté
qu'il ya une à brno graphie féministe ça
n'existe pas 90% des comptes des
contenus sont des contenus millions pour
les femmes et qui en effet pousse
certains jeunes gens avoir recours à des
pratiques humiliantes pour les pour les
jeunes femmes il ya très peu de choses
sont faites contre la pornographie et ça
s'est il faut le dire c'est une
porcherie quelque part c'est bien mais
elle exprime le deuil de ce qu'on ne
peut plus faire dans la réalité je suis
pas sûr à l'esprit moi je pense
justement non moi je compte contraire
c'est parce qu'on a plus d'enseignement
parce que pour les gamins qui regardent
là on voit en ce que c'est la norme on
voit cette bien c'est ce que je dis on
voit que les sites pornographiques
l'idéal masculin qui est en train de
craquer et on voit ce qu'on est en train
de perdre heureusement qu'on le perd
manger moins on voit le l'idéalisation
horrible que fait l'homme de la femme
c'est à dire par assujettissement sur
les sites pornographiques qui explose
parce que dans la réalité ne peut être
moi je vais faire moi je préfère que ce
soit médiatisé par des parts des
représentations culturelles qui soit
belle artistique dans la réalité plutôt
que par le porno et au jeu quand on est
gosse quand on déconstruit justement et
toute la culture en disant ton la
galanterie c'est une forme de sexisme
les carmen de bizet c'est une forme de
sexisme quand on découvre
qu est ce qu il faut que l'on se
retrouve avec avec la photographie
la sous culture populaire zorap et s'est
montrée dans la culture un traître dans
l'histoire dans la culée léger et les
mâles
que les jeunes de votre île ne lis plus
la litté de la littérature une liste
plus marivaux une liste publiée il
découpe des chanteurs de rap qui chante
maintenant grosse plus grosse [ __ ] et
ironie j'ai regarder du porno et je suis
pas sûr que ce soit meilleur dans la
vision que ça vécu de la prendre
c'est important parce que vous avez
laissé sous-entendre quelque chose et je
veux être très clair à ce sujet là vous
avez dit me dites pas qu'il ya du porno
féministe oui je ne crois pas je nage
libre 2e il
je ne pense pas qu'il ait dû porte nos
féministes et donc on voit très bien ce
à quoi sert le porno on voit très bien
les tendances en effet à la domination à
la violence aujourd'hui il ya des
développements de porno extrêmes qui
sont en réalité de la pédocriminalité
d'une part et de la torture d'autre part
et donc il faut en effet rétroactivement
accessible en plus fait très facilement
accessible c'est très dangereux ça
participe aussi d'une construction
culture des femmes japonaises qui joue
dans ses films disent qu'elles n'ont pas
eu le choix entre
tyler derrière la caméra et devant la
caméra va rappeler qu'il ya de
véritables personnes des non pas des
actrices mais des femmes qui je pense
ont souvent violées sur ce type de
plateau et c'est quelque chose qu'on n'a
pas encore intégré dans ce qu'est la
culture du vial jan ce mouvement a quand
même libéré une certaine parole et là où
vous vous trompez peut-être c'est que
moi même je suis surpris de voir à quel
point des amis des vieilles familles des
deux jeunes amis me disent tout d'un
coup ce qu'elles ont subi dans leur
enfance et je peux vous dire que je ne
savais pas que c'était à ce point là
tout d'un coup la mer se retire et on
voit que sous l'eau il y avait des pneus
crevés et des rats morts
bon sens votre geste à france inter
c'était quoi c'était un geste féministe
j'arrive pas à dire que je suis
féministe et parce que j'ai pas envie de
d'appartenir d'être enfermé voir dans un
club mais en même temps je suis donc
nationaux non mais je trouve que on veut
toujours que les choses soient soient
noirs soirée de dimanche alors que ça
dépend de son histoire ça dépend des
gens ça dépend de l'éducation ça dépend
de la culture ça dépend de la grande
idée parce que c'était un mcdonnell est
en moi ce que je suis humoriste moi je
suis pas militante donc quand j'ai fait
sauter ça c'était avant tout pour faire
rire ça fait rire des gens qui savaient
pas rire des gens mais ce qui a été
gênant pour moi c'est que je me dis on
voit des nanas à poil en permanence à
pose pas de problème et de dire c'est
mon corps je suis libre et je vous
emmerde et ben là je me fais insulter je
me prends un tourbillon de merde sur la
gueule sur les réseaux sociaux et ça ça
me dérange voilà mais ce qui est bien
c'est que ça a évolué il ya des limites
et les gros mots jeux loto
laurent tu veux dire quelque chose oui
je trouve ce débat passionnant vraiment
passionnant ce truc que je comprends pas
c'est quel est l'intérêt de donner la
parole aux femmes en fait
[Musique]
voilà génie d'acier merci d'avoir été
les frères ennemis le non
circoncis la
semaine prochaine à lui
et voilà je dois bella qu'une pas là
dessus
du jamais vu le jour
[Applaudissements]
en
revanche j'ai eu à vivre bien d'une
émission carré de sable à 15 journées
laurent baffie est toujours là et social
michel blanc
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
michel blanc
noémie lenoir
will i am le gris
un vrai casting benetton assez les piles
par célèbes lille c'est à michel et bien
oui vous avez 16 ans qu'on s'est pas vu
la dernière fois c'était en 2002 votre
dernier film comme réalisateur embrassez
qui vous voudrez et aujourd'hui vous
voyez comment danse donc et la fausse
suite du précédent que vous venez de
réaliser alors à l'époque vous étiez
extrêmement angoissés est-ce que ça va
mieux oh ben non ça c'est dans les gènes
ah ouais ça m'étonnerait que je meure
tranquille rassurez moi tu vas mourir à
bari vous n'êtes pas pris de médicaments
là non maintenant j'ai confiance ouais
vous êtes toujours un peu hypocondriaque
oui je sais c'est quoi michel votre
maladie préféré à ben non moi je verrais
un peu tout un
ba oui je suis non ma vie serait très
ennuyeux et votre médicament préféré
celui que vous préférez prendre c'est
quoi or et non tout va mais deviendra
corps de m
touba non même les génériques c'est pas
la phobie c gepa celles là ont plus qu
un jeu blanc
shell
toi et
[Musique]
williams oui quand j'ai appris que vos
parents vous ont rappelé williams parce
que j'étais femme de william leymergie
alors pas du tout non
[Rires]
c'est bizarre mais bon
je précise quand même nos amis
téléspectateurs que c'est william leng
il est pas beau liam les bills avaient
pas maintenant quand à ses célèbres pour
que les gens arrivent à renoncer bien on
a toujours été très difficile très
difficile la baisse bigdil dans la rue
c'est marrant comme non la ligue il
parce que c'est pas un peu chiffres et
des lettres quoi le tirage compliqué
avec
lui ça vous êtes passés en fait deux ont
connu sa tête mais on sait jamais
comment il s'appelle on connaît son nom
mais on sait pas comment l'écrire c'est
ça c'est déjà pas mal vous êtes
populaire chez les adolescents c'est
plus populaires ces adolescents que la
masturbation et
les dormeurs jusqu'à 1000
points communs et d'ailleurs les ados
ont donné votre nom en hommage à une
barrette de shit à se voit la ligue bill
oui
c'est bien servi
je pense
il dit ça en présence de michel blanc
que vous êtes le jean claude dusse du
21e
ça me fait vraiment ça vous fabriquez
vient d'apprendre qu'il va jamais baisé
les comptes
rappel chanter ses bourreaux jeu non
sans rire
on voit bonamia
je vais
les sages n'ont émis
tiers est toujours aussi jolie mais
commence et vendu votre âme au diable je
suis sur mon nom mon âme à dieu à dieu
non mais en fait c'est génétique ah
ouais ma mère à la 64 ans ça soit pas
dit on est ici ce soir pour la suite de
aladin qui s'appelle al abdallah alors
vous michel et william j'étais dans le
un pas dans le 2 est-ce que sur le
tournage du 2 les gens
regretté l'absence de michel et de et de
william ou alors ils sont six
mais on aura un troisième je pense alors
vous adorez les suit en fait vous avez
joué dans astérix et obélix 2 rechal 3
le transporteur 4 en fait je fais
toujours les suites quoi mais c'est bien
ouais j'ai fait 15 millions d'entrées au
cinéma jusqu'à maintenant quand même
assez cool de calculer comme ça et
maintenant c'est l'heure des infos 2
vise haut
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et on commence par l'événement de la
semaine ont orchestré agrandi djebla
manuel valls sera candidat aux
municipales de barcelone on en est
débarrassé
et j'avais rien demandé au public ouais
on est débarrassé de ben ali elle va ça
leur fait plaisir
non manuel valls c'est un beau symbole
de courage le mec a perdu tout ce qu'il
y avait moyen de perdre en france et il
se dit tiens si j'allais me faire
humilier en espagne
etc pour lionel messi que ça va faire de
la concurrence à barcelone parce qu'il
est un peu pareil valls à dire que tu
pense qu'il va partir à gauche qui file
à droite et dans la série la fuite des
cerveaux nous avons aussi cette semaine
laurent wauquiez qui est allé en
allemagne et il a encensé ângela merkel
notez bien que lui reprochaient à la
chancelière d'accueillir n'importe qui
en allemagne il est maintenant bien
placés pour voir que ça se confirme le
plus amusant c'est que lors de son
fameux cours enregistré un nombre jamais
dû être enregistrés
il avait dit à propos de mme merkel
cette phrase là pour lui trouvaient du
charisme il fallait se lever de bonne
heure et ben faut croire que depuis lors
il a mis sort allait plutôt dans l'aude
les français à l'étranger encore avec le
président emmanuel macron étaient à
l'onu oui s'est excusé après son
discours auprès du pupitre carré lui
avait trop taper dessus ouais bah y'a eu
très vite une réaction surprenante sur
twitter alexandre benalla ah bon on ne
peut pas taper sur les pupitres non plus
affaire benhaddad toujours il ya une
avocate parisienne qui a déposé la
marque benalla le nom pour vendre des
armes et des feux d'artifice alors sans
doute également des déguisements de
policiers chez machine mais on va
s'arrêter ou parce que peut déposer
d'autres marques aurore bergé pour
vendre des vestes réversibles
christophe castaner pour vendre des
brosses à reluire ou françois d'origine
pour vendre des paillassons sais pas et
clou du spectacle la marque gérard
collomb pour des couches conférence
excuses
sans transition jean marie le pen
hospitalisé en raison d'une fièvre
persistante cette semaine on y va mieux
non non rassurez vous il a fait un petit
peu de température mais il était plutôt
content parce qu'ils étaient entre 39 et
d'ailleurs il s'est sorti beaucoup mieux
quand il a appris ceci évidemment c'est
que médecins sans frontières a annoncé
que l'accord youth ne se diriger plus
vers marseille et je vais vous dire
c'est pas mal pour les migrants non plus
quand on fuit la guerre c'est pas pour
risquer de se prendre une rafale de
kalachnikov à marseille et dont la
politique avec aux européennes nicolas
dupont aignan qui part seul pour
supplanter les républicains et le
rassemblement national et je vais vous
dire mon avis ça s'est passé comme ça il
a dit hey et qui m'aime me suive
et puis voilà
elle revient au centre c'est un petit
coup et d'aucuns
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rentrée politique de françois bayrou lol
entre nous la rentrée politique de
françois bayrou on n'y croit pas
beaucoup hein ça sonne un peu comme le
retour en formule 1 pour michael
schumacher on n'y croit pas beaucoup
écologie
le budget 2010 9 du gouvernement prévoit
800 suppressions de postes au sein de
pôle emploi
mais
ses couilles au laos est mort wemmel
avantage c'est que les mecs devront même
pas traversé la rue pour aller trouver
du travail ils sont déjà au bon endroit
société
est bien ce petit pépin portent tous le
feu vert du comité d'éthique et pour la
pma c'est normal que le feu soit au vert
[Applaudissements]
n'est pas déçu outre la pma le comité
d'éthique s'est également prononcé pour
l'auto congélation des ovocytes voilà
donc d'un point de vue sociétal on peut
considérer que véronique courjault était
avant-gardiste et ensuite marlène
schiappa marlène schiappa annonce la
première condamnation pour outrage
sexistes l'homme a dû payer 300 euros
damende parce qu'il avait traité une
femme de sale p je serai laurent baffie
j'appellerai déjà ma banque pour
connaître les modalités de crédit j'ai
cassé mon père
[Musique]
politique quatre paires national
en belgique aux élections communales ya
un candidat qui a été rejetée par
facebook qui peut pas faire campagne sur
facebook à cause de son nom je vous le
donne en mille cet homme s'appelle luc
anus alors où est non alors on n'est pas
là pour se moquer du patronyme des gens
mais je tiens quand même à saluer le
panache de ses parents qui connaissant
très bien les soucis que son portait le
nom and us ont quand même choisi de le
prénommer lui qui est l'anagramme dû
m'occuper
paul
fashion week carla bruni-sarkozy
défilent pour deutsch et gabbana cg dire
qu'elles défilent encore jeu ça plutôt
bien et c'est vrai que quand on regarde
son visage le terme haute couture prend
[Rires]
voilà voilà voilà toujours kim
kardashian assister aux premiers défilés
de sa fille qui a 5 ans mannequin 5 ans
jeune ans et trois jeunes s'est passé à
5 ans elle a encore les doigts trop
petit pour se faire vomir elle peut pas
être même en cas
et
passons à l'un des plus grands écrivains
de son temps michel houellebecq s'est
marié celui qui a écrit soumission va
enfin vraiment savoir ce que c'est et
malheureusement pour de nombreux parents
ce mariage sonne la fin de la menace
parce que moi ma mère elle me disait
bros toi bien les dents sinon tu finiras
seul comme michel houellebecq est alors
il s'est marié people encore cassandra
forêt la soeur de jacques ferait vient
d'avoir un bébé avec le fils d'arnaud
lagardère alors je pense qu'ils
connaissent un peu la famille donc la
mannequin belge jade et marié à arnaud
lagardère s'est peut-être pas très clair
comme ça j'ai amené l'arbre généalogique
ça va vous simplifier la vie voilà en
fait les départs en forêt ont eu deux
filles jade et cassandra et jade elle
est avec arnaud lagardère qui avec une
première fois mais un fils lagardère et
puis si vous voulez ils ont fait un an
fois là et
ça s'est tellement clair
voilà et jade forêt est à la fois la
grand mère et la tante du bébé de sa
soeur dont le mari et son beau fils mais
aussi son beau-frère vu que son père est
aussi l'oncle par alliance de son propre
petit fils et je pense que du coup c'est
beaucoup plus clair
et maintenant c'est la culture
c'est pas beau la retouche de la semaine
dan vaut il est danois d'origine
vietnamienne et vit à berlin autant vous
dire c'est des rares personnes à aimer
la choucroute aux harengs sauce aigre
doux et il m'a exposé à bordeaux
jusqu'au 28 octobre dans la nef du capc
est connu pour mélanger les genres la
photo le marbre le tissu des documents à
voir ici une une première oeuvre de tad
bowie pose à côté du plug annales de
marianne james est
là c'est aussi l'image qui est violente
et bat bordeaux l'artiste fera une
installation spéciale pour le lieu comme
il l'avait déjà fait par exemple dans
cette église voilà où on le voit jésus
un peu démunis comme ça sur un
échafaudage et c'est vrai que quand lui
ai expliqué que sa mère était vierge et
ben il l'a dit les bras m'en tombent
la même oeuvre d'un autre point de vue
on va voir parce que c'est vrai si la
vie d'amy plein de choses donc si un
jour vous jouez à pierre feuille ciseaux
avec d'anovo vous avez déjà une petite
idée de ce qu'ils pourraient choisir
alors c'est parfois massives mais c'est
parfois sobre on va avoir une autre
oeuvre ici on le voit à côté de kate
moss
est une autre que très jolie de deux
doigts uniquement david guetta en train
de composer son nouveau tube et après un
seul doigt en bronze oeuvres qu'il
aurait créé au lendemain du d'un
douloureux examen de la prostate et
parfois il s'inspire de la
déconstruction vous allez voir ça
c'était voileux
lustres avant le lustre après on dirait
le carlton de lille après une soirée
avec des escales même le luxe très
démontée et est ici ici voilà d'être moi
je suis pas capable de dire s'il s'agit
d'une heure ou de la caf de francis
heaulme
et puis petite dernière a effectivement
oeuvres qu'on intitulerait nordahl le
landais fait du baby sitting
oui il en faut pour
aller si c'est au capc de bordeaux parce
que l'art c'est comme la politique c'est
pas parce qu'on n'y comprend rien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
au brésil à 0
sur scène apparaît landes où la france
et maintenant c'est l'heure de la promo
qui s'affiche c'est shopping
[Musique]
alors un artiste c'est aussi un code
barre
[Musique]
on a émis le noir bonsoir vous êtes ici
ce soir pour allah 2 donc un film de
lionel steketee en salle 3 octobre avec
kavala djamel debbouze eric judor ramzy
bedia c'est un peu le chien et les
veines des comiques français non
exactement ils sont tous là et il ya
aussi des guest on en reparlera le pitch
est créé dames c'est le rôle principal
vous jouez une bombe et le film tué des
millions d'entrées c'est ça le pitch
c'est exactement ça le vrai pitch et
aladin qui va récupérer sa fiancée jamel
debbouze la mariée de force et donc du
coup ils traversent moi je suis une
hôtesse de l'air et je raconte
l'histoire et j'ai un moment je suis
ramzy qui est le qui est le bac je ne
fasse plus tôt lui l'habitude de fumer
les valeurs
bancaires et dames qui sont mis au pas
les jeux tout est réglé il ya un
terrible dictateur qui joué par jamel
debbouze qui veut prendre bagdad et
épouser la princesse heureusement il à
son génie eric judor médias mais là
aussi son génie ramzy bedia et ramzy
bedia se transforme en femme etc vous en
fait
c'est vous voilà pour angels la
princesse qu'est ce que vaut pitch est
bien celle était bien là mais c'est faux
culs mais ces langues c'est bourré de
clins d'oeil d'anachronisme il ya une
photo de michel blanc qu'on achète au
marché noir est présent dans le deuxième
ris monadé mais j'ai dit oui avec
plaisir un sûr il ya deux part-dieu ans
christophe colomb et ya frédéric lopez
dans le rôle de frédéric lopez
exactement on regarde à quoi ça
ressemble magnéto serge
chanson i'm a pc venu hoarau de bagdad
juste si positif on répète ça rastaman
sais pas si tu paies de merlan et moi
les peuls qui fait peur
bon ben c'est reparti une télé porte à
bagdad on va libérer la princesse
ok c'est un petit cafouillage au
démarrage
on s'est joint à lampe magique bienvenue
au marché noir oui y'a que des mecs ici
il suffit que vous rendiez jalouse la
princesse pour cela il faudrait qu'elle
pouvoir et qu'une autre femme alors vous
me trouvez comment c'est qu'ils à la
rapine mais deviennent visibles et une
tournure ont devisé
jjg vous êtes le maître 90
[Musique]
ça va cartonner
je salue
alors nous est métisse d'être même une
publicité vivante pour le métissage
merci à votre père était métropolitain
votre mère réunionnaise
et vous avez appris à cinq ans que votre
mère était ce qu'on appelle une enfant
de la creuse alors les gens savent pas
ce que c'est à dire que à une époque le
gouvernement français a décidé
pratiquement de kidnapper des enfants à
la réunion les a mais en france on leur
en croire qu'ils doivent être éduqués en
fait souvent il était garçon de ferme
c'était pour repeupler pour accabler la
creuse et melzer et oui c'est exactement
michel exactement en fait j'ai découvert
ça un jour je regardais un reportage et
g j'ai eu l'impression de voir ma mère
ouais et je lui en ai parlé et j'ai dit
c'est bizarre j'ai vu un reportage
étaient des enfants de la réunion j'ai
l'impression d'avoir vu et vous vous
rendez compte que je ne connaissais pas
ma mère en fait je connaissais pas son
histoire et ça remonte qu'à cinq ans
ouais et donc à nous avait caché tout ça
est donc je les pose toutes ces
questions et elle me dit effectivement
j'étais une enfant de la creuse
j'ai eu la chance que j'ai été prise par
une famille d'allemands qui ont été très
gentils qu'ils sont bien occupés d'elle
sortie certains se faisait carrément
violer qu'elle est dans des fermes et
tout mais elle a eu de la chance de
tomber sur une super famille allemande
d'ailleurs que j'embrasse alors ce qu'il
faut lire ça a duré de
1963 à 1982 dont ses gammes relativement
récent cette hsitoire alors vous
grandissez dans l'essonne et alors il ya
la légende évidemment je pense que les
gens de noémie lenoir passe absolument
extraordinaire donc elle a dit dans
l'essonne dans une cité et un jour elle
va acheter des timbres à la poste de gif
sur yvette hélas le destin
extraordinaire elle tombe sur une dame
qui lui dit je vais moi j'étais
mannequin à l' agence ford t franchement
vous devriez essayer d'être mannequin
gens nous contactent et l' agence ford à
la châtre et un faux pas du coup
c'est important pour j'ai complètement
ne croyez pas du tout en fait j'avais
chez moi je change ma mère je disais
cette femme qui m'a
interpellé que m'a demandé si je voulais
être mannequin ma mère était toute
excitée elle a du bon d'accord on va y
aller on a appelé ford
était qui était ma première agence du
coup j'ai commencé comme ça et je suis
parti direct vous avez fait une carrière
incroyable donc parce que quinze ans
plus tard je vais tout de suite à la fin
mai vous devenez égérie l'oréal l'une
des rares françaises à faire partie des
anges de victoria's secret tu vois là
c'est quand même incroyable coup de
chance incroyable coup du destin alors
qu'elle est quand même super mal foutu
et 10 ans plus tard vous fait une
tentative de suicide qu'est ce qui s'est
passé n'aurait mis parce qu'on s'est pas
vu depuis en fait
face on a envie d'en parler en fait
parce que
voilà sous les ponts en parle on en
parle pas alors aujourd'hui ça va
aujourd'hui je vais très bien ouais
ouais grâce grâce à beaucoup de choses
grâce à ma famille grâce
à ma fille non mais grâce à la vie j'ai
repris goût à la vie et
ça va
wes en forme et ça va très bien bush au
nez de tout le monde en parle en 2001
c'était en 2001 il y avait déjà baffie
il y avait aussi méline magnéto serge
est ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
devenir son esclave sexuelle
[Applaudissements]
c'est entendu
mais mu
mais
mais les bienvenus
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
mais tu serais tu prêt de karamoja
devenir son esclave sexuelle
c'est pour elles ne sont pas très
élevées que ce que nous l'annoncer
l'irlande
se retrouve après la plus suivie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'émission vous permet de savoir quelle
journée en compagnie de michel blanc
[Applaudissements]
non non
[Musique]
c'est l'heure de lardy quiz
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en hommage à michel blanc et noémie
lenoir on va faire un hard et quils sont
vos couleurs
le winner aura droit à un éloge de la
part de thierry ardisson le looser aura
droit à un éloge mais par laurent baffie
ah oui
alors testez vos buzzer d'abord on
[Musique]
à toi rémy faut que tu appuies
santana
quand vous pensez avoir la réponse
évidemment vous appuyez sur votre buzzer
et vous répondez se mettre avec ma fille
oui oui des capotes longs mois des
capotes
première âge petite taille le tibet
à paris est un village
de près
comment s'appelle le peintre qui ne
peint en noir
apaise réconforte console ou soulage
soulac cela les appuis en enduit foot
c'est que ça marche je pense que ça
commence
[Musique]
là c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
pourquoi néron adorent et il la couleur
verte
parce que sa mère portait une bague en
émeraude parce qu'il aimait courir nus
dans l'herbe parce qu'il était né un
soir de lune verte ou parce qu'il
adorait manger des poireaux
[Musique]
parce qu'il était né un soir de l'unité
nord
parce que sa mère portait une bague
émeraude morts
il adorait courir nus dans l'herbe au
bénin on vient dire non on a tout fait
vas-y vas-y méchali et leur estime c'est
une victoire est là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il était dingue du v10 était dingue du
vert dans les jeux du ciel qui se met
toujours les écuries verte décès mandé
des bleus il avait une collection de
l'émeraude et néron adorait moment pas
parce que mes shows adoré les poireaux
et l'herbe le magic dans cet effort
pourquoi les blues de chirurgiens sont
elles verte parce qu'on brasse paraît a
lancé la mode en 15 150 parce que c'est
la couleur qui fait le mieux ressortir
le sont parce que le vert est la couleur
de l'espoir ou parce que blanc c est
trop salissant
[Musique]
je frappe comme un dingue la musique ne
sort pas oui parce que ambroise paré a
lancé la mort
parce que c'est la couleur qui fait le
plus ressentir bravo messieurs
[Applaudissements]
alors là c'est facile attention
de quelle couleur sont les boîtes noires
des avions
[Musique]
je persiste à dire que ça marche quand
quelqu'un me et non nous fait le premier
à qu'ils étaient pour lui je suis très
mauvais soir dans le jeu parmi les
tableaux suivants lequel n'a pas été
réalisé par un enfant de moins de 5 ans
[Musique]
je pense bravo
bravo michel blanc et en fait des autres
ont été faits par des gens de l'âge de
2-3 carrie cinq ans effectivement donc
on en est où là
blanc prend la tête
[Applaudissements]
quelle maladie n'existe pas la fièvre
bleue la cne rose la mycose violacé ou
le syndrome du struma argenté
la mycose je la sais pas comment tu sais
ça fait trois fois
le syndrome du schtroumpf argent c'est
assez hallucinant ça existe un c'est une
maladie qui s'appelle largué rythme et
qui est provoqué par l'absorption
d'argent colloïdal ça m'arrive souvent
j'ai jamais ressenti de 100
m attention
là c'est vraiment une question de
rapidité
cette ville est exclu
citez moi un personnage de fiction avec
un nom de couleurs
[Musique]
je perdrais la france libère wii black
panther est ce que ce tabac
et 26 challenge
[Applaudissements]
on est à égalité donc le super banco
[Musique]
vous êtes prêts quelle est la couleur la
plus populaire dans le monde
le bleu le rouge le vert le noir
c'est moi
[Musique]
oui c'est le bleu le blanc mais comment
vous savez ça l'est parce que je le sais
bah oui la réponse est bon chez michel
blanck pardon non
[Applaudissements]
michel blanc adroits les loges et l'anti
loges serait pour williams
michel quoi de plus naturel
que de faire l'éloge de l'acteur le plus
culte du cinéma français culte parce que
vous êtes la coqueluche des français les
i pas ça parce que vous êtes
hypocondriaque michel il n'y a pas un
français qui ne pensent pas à vous
lorsqu'il prend le télésiège
ses vacances au ski
ou lorsqu il effleure du pied ils tous
dingues sera claj ans n'était pas un
français qui n'est une pensée émue pour
vous
lorsqu'il se prend un râteau
alors qu'il pensait lui aussi que sur un
malentendu ça pouvait marcher
cultes michèle parce que vous avez su
sublimer le rôle du loser magnifique au
physique pas facile pour en faire un
héros que des générations et des
générations de français n'oublieront
jamais michel michel vous savez que les
français vous aime tellement qu'il
pourrait tout vous pardonner même les
bronzés 3 et ça
c'est une preuve d'amour
[Applaudissements]
bon je me mentais lentille blonde si
l'ofj de vue d'amener dit rihanna c'est
une carrière naissante i qui démarre
grâce à une présence inouïe un sens de
la promotion à toute épreuve une
répartie désarçonnante 1 et il prouve à
lui seul qu'on peut allier
acting et drogues douces
oui elle ne fera rien de sa vie il le
sait mais tant qu'on ne parle pas de son
micro pénis il est heureux
allez voir williams
[Musique]
on continue avec celle de la promo qui
s'affiche
[Musique]
alors michel blanc regard est pas dit qu
il ya maintenant cinq ans
qu'est ce que c'est que je
leur ai dit vous êtes ici ce soir pour
nous parler du film voyez comment dans
ce dont ils avaient violé des
bénéficiaires pourquoi il faut
absolument aller voir ce film plutôt
qu'à la 2 donc le film de noémie lenoir
alors voyez comment danse donc c'est la
fausse suite en fait de rang brasser qui
vous voudrez le dernier film que vous
oubliez réalisé en 2002 il ya déjà 16
ans 16 ans j'étais sûr d'avoir envie de
réaliser des films
ouais la preuve bah oui mais pourquoi
saison parce que j'ai été un peu occupé
à réclamer des dialogues ou de rhume un
peu ouais j'ai scénarii puis j'ai tourné
des rôles et puis je trouvais pas de
sujet qui m'a emballé ouais ouais le
troisième se sera j'ai calculé en en
je suis pas sûr d'être là pour vous
accueillir non plus
franchement nous et on verra ce que ça
donne
alors vous êtes dit si je fais pas un
film maintenant j'en ferai plus qua non
non c'est parce que la très bonne idée
de de récupérer un petit peu de la
saveur des personnages d'une embrassez
qui vous voudrez m'a été suggérée par le
producteur de dracé il marion et puis
d'un seul coup ça a fait son chemin je
me suis dit mais si là je prenais juste
les caractères de quelques personnages
et que je j'essaie de leur faire vivre
autre chose avec d'autres individus
notamment notamment je suis la reine le
très loquace même quand on parle de lui
c'est clair pas il savait qu évident
mais il faut dire qu'il a un rire
complet
mais j'aurais pu l'appeler le film
embrassez qui vous voudrez fondu ce qui
serait
le retour ou leur tour effectivement
alors donc c'est une fausse suite vous
dites que vous n'avez pas revu embrassez
qui vous voudrez mais même pas relu le
scénario vous dit c'est pas un film pour
les gens qui ont vu le premier à quinze
ans en fait non non non non je n'ai pas
la prétention de penser que mon oeuvre
est absolument inévitable
donc je me suis dit il ya beaucoup de
gens qui n'ont pas vu embrasser et il
faut que ces gens là s'amuse quand même
et que même ils s'amusent autant dans sa
muse corner on retrouve effectivement
des personnages du du précédent et des
nouveaux alors le casting à karin viard
carole bouquet charlotte rampling
jacques dutronc jean paul rouve william
leng il est sara martins réaction aux
liens
le pitch le pitch y en a pas c'est dur
mais est ce qu'on peut dire c'est qu'on
suit comme ça sur un rythme assez dire
voletant des personnages assez
hétéroclite assez fouillée assez marrant
les parents paumés les enfants rebelles
les âmes ont contrarié voilà mais bon ya
pas de pics ça s'appelle voyez comme on
danse parce qu'en fait ça court dans
tous les sens oui c'est ça certes un
tourbillon quoi ouais comme le monde en
sur les sur les braises pour pas se
brûler voilà c'est ça s'arrête de danse
et j'aurais exactement rit jean il se
doit les ont regardés quoi ça ressemble
magnéto serge verreault et dans une
salle pas ce pays depuis sa naissance
malheureusement ce n'était pas de la
prime excusez moi je prends tes affaires
et qui passe mais tout va les tuer va
coûter plus cher on sait bien qu'on
charge sociale va se passer à pai avait
dû grave ça et politis aussi à huy en
drame que ce qui se passe on va où dans
le meilleur appui après des jours et ça
devient maman je suis enceinte sont pas
les plus brefs et autres dettes c'est en
bas à
ce soit moi même situation toi je te
sera jamais une famille normale bon
alors là c'est carton plein
bertrand est en garde à vue
aucune idée
tu risque gros
je suis
peut être contrarié
je pense toujours que tel que j'ai bien
tes trousses ça me fait pas rire suis
sûr qu'on suit je suis bien qu'est ce
qui se passe je sens qu'on cache quelque
chose mais je te cache rien du tout
vous fait rien je gêne et war s'cusez
moi sur ce que c'est le bruit sur la
poignée ça peut prêter à confusion mais
vous vous devriez fermer votre baignoire
parce que ça aussi ça peut prêter à
confusion
[Musique]
était forte et pleine confiance et pas
la peine soit réparée c'est moi qui les
gaz et
[Applaudissements]
serena si je comprends bien tu as mais
tu as un viol c'est moi qui ai quittés
je voulais le faire depuis longtemps
mais elle menacer de tout raconter
elle n'était par les couilles pour toi
n'y a pas beaucoup de prise
tendance à la bise olten vous seuls 3
des gens parler dans le film de tran a
les filles me chambrent il est comme un
grand dans les dialogues ouais non mais
c'est excellent ah non mais le film n'a
pas perdu la main c'est gentil de me le
dire mais je vous le dis on rassure mais
non mais c'est vrai
mais j'ai tourné qu'un légume
comment ça s'est passé alors on a arrosé
beaucoup
alors vous êtes connu d'ailleurs tous
les deux sur le tournage des souvenirs
de jean paul rouve c'est son côté nié
maladroit qui nous assure qu'il n'est ni
n'y ait ni maladroit il a un univers
parallèle à lui
très différent du nôtre mais fort ouais
c'est ça qui est sacré qui me plaît
beaucoup des silences très éloquent
alors évidemment ça passe pas bien en
télé
quand tu écoutes mais non mais c'était
c'était formidable de son expérience
formidable le cinéma est une grande
famille
effectivement s'étaient rencontrés sur
les souvenirs quand le sort s'en
branlent sait d'avancé ce supporter
non mais non mais c'est franchement
c'était trop cool j'ai trop kiffé ce
titre ô bien merci
[Applaudissements]
si la césar ça quand même qu'ils
apprennent un peu non ah ben non plus on
est court mieux c'est moins content ça
prend la blague m on
commence à te répondre jusqu'au 6 mai il
ya quelqu'un qui sait bien répondu aux
césar quand tu l'as eu c'est mathilde
seigner alors on lui remet tait pas ça
sur la tête lan moi j'ai une grande
tendresse pour elle aussi j'aime mon nom
mais
en fait ça me faisait marrer mais je les
ai faut que je la fasse sortir de scène
parce qu'elle voulait elle voulait à la
fois ci s'excuser s'expliquer et elle
s'en faire et je disais
et mais c'est moi je comprends très très
bien elle l avait un trouvé formidable
son partenaire alors joey starr est
maximale voilà j'aime at il comprenait
pas que des gens aient pas le ls et
arbre n'a été déçu ledesma ce gascon
fonds mignon magnéto serge terre dans un
second rôle michel blanc dans l'exercice
de l'état
il s'agit du premier césar de cette
carrière après cette nomination dont
quatre en maille orateurs pour tmx
soirée le se lire je vous trouve très
beau et les témoins
[Applaudissements]
dray je voudrais juste dire à un tout
petit mot je voudrais qu'ils montent
didier ouais parce que j'adore je suis
ravi que tu l'aies michel mais je
voulais que ce sens fin j'ai voilà
pardon
voilà didier t aujourd'hui doux sinon je
propose je propose un truc elle viens
viens viens viens peut avoir la garde
alternée
des vacances scolaires et les jantes et
parce que il vient à son secours alors
que la situation est gênante il a un bon
changement il a très bon enfin michel
bien sûr on le sait bon alors il ya
autre chose qui vous rapproche tous les
deux à part les souvenirs effectivement
c'est la prise de conscience de votre
nature d'artistes alors michel puget
tirs en troisième
vous étiez extrêmement timide et un jour
jouer les précieuses ridicules et la
bouffe est rien et vous vous sentez bien
et vous vous dites iliaque l'acte est
bien dans la vie
on jouait les un petit extrait des
pièces qu'on étudiait en français et
donc ont bien une petite estrade devant
le tableau noir et donc je skie est très
bizarre c'est que le prof a dit qu'
est-ce qu'il veut jouer et alors moi
j'ai été horriblement timide et
introverti et c'est ma main c'est
pratiquement levée malgré moi jouer et
je commençais à donner la réplique les
mes potes se sont marrés d'un seul coup
c'est comme si j'avais découvert alors
tiens à parler d'univers parallèles
parce que celui la vie dedans mais j'ai
eu l'impression qu'il y avait un autre
monde les dégroupages était bien dedans
voilà et alors william lui vous avez
devant vous et du théâtre le samedi
après midi il tient assez complexe et
parce qu'à l'époque j'étais en surpoids
ouais tu te fais c'était un peu
grassouillet et puis je suis monté sur
scène en fait je devais être en couches
culottes et 1b du timon tib le fera
non je sais pas si je vais le faire et
tout j'ai pas trop envie de me montrer
comme ça en couche culotte devant tout
le monde et tout ça est en fait je les
fais finalement je me suis offert vous
en faites vous deviez avoir un tee shirt
quand vous êtes arrivé sur scène nous
avait enlevé le petit shirt qui était
courageux parce que vous avez quand même
un peu des bourrelets je crois mais je
pense que c'était assez mignon mais les
petits bourrelets oui voilà c'est
désolant mais voilà alors vous montez
sur scène torse nu le public rit vous
amusez vous dites ça m'a libéré voilà
donc ces semences maintenant c'est que
ça c'est vendre est pareil le moment on
se rend compte que finalement en se
montrant telle qu'on est finalement bel
avantage qu'ils avaient c'est qu'ils
pouvaient s'achète s'ils ne sont que
j'emploie il avait des bus 4 voilà un
acteur qui monte un acteur qui ne
descendent pas william leng il et michel
blanc bravo damas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et maintenant c'est le blind test c'est
quoi le thème le tellement à voir le
blender
[Musique]
le thème du blind test de ce choix en
hommage à michel blanc qui fait la une
vous avez vous fait la une de chauves
magazine
ça existe que ça bien sinon c'est un
montage a dû tout ce n'est pas mais je
savais pas je pensais que vous étiez ou
non rester c'est pas possible si c'est
trop bien parler soit à quatre pages
dans mes gros penne saint
renan luce à son chauffe et donc le
blind test évidemment ces chanteurs
chaud le gagnant devra célébrer sa
victoire en faisant comme au football
quand on sait quand il marque un but
quoi sa voix la branche et la guitare
pour china guitare en tenue de tambow
roi jacques rogge mad as
[Musique]
4 music
nom william sheller non ces petites
bisbilles
t'as pas besoin de ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
tu savais
comme tu as cru qui peut s'appuyer sur
le buzzer bah oui mais désolé mannequin
la base donc pascal obispo donc
effectivement williams l'aide qu'il
vient de se réveiller enfin et il est là
il ya un biberon va plutôt
optimiser la musique
mobile un risque
[Applaudissements]
ayrault
tu vois tout va bien mais attention sa
fille chante donc laisse moi gagner
attention musique on peut dire sans
forcer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec un phantom une grosse fan base sont
peut retrouver en concert la partie
hybride orly
booba attention on se concentre musique
je connais
non phil collins
[Applaudissements]
m
oui mais seul un gros lag il a marqué
trois
contrôles antidopage
quand il est en sommeil ça mérite
attention ça c'est extrêmement compliqué
bon
je pense que c'est mieux musiques
[Musique]
du monde coupe du monde de football un
plan non
au
brésil et coupe du monde au brésil
[Musique]
et la langue de race de chien
c'est patrick évidemment des contenus
qui ça peut pas être caniche non pas
faux et fait qu'à me suis fait mal
il a un an de race de chien
un chat mais jean
[Musique]
paul bouche non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est musique
j'attends
[Applaudissements]
sur rai
les beaux objets non plus on n'est pas
obligé d'écouter la chanson trop
longtemps assez insupportable je dois me
dire attention est là la suite est pire
musique
series et comment ils s'attribuent
plus en entier au
lacet
c'est là suis là là là celui qui va
trouver ça il aura toute mon admiration
musique
[Musique]
les garçons bouchers
étrange choix hadji-lazaro leader des
garçons bouchers et c'est une reprise de
no milk today des armes à m'énerver
[Musique]
dans un groupe il est dans les vegans
maintenant maintenant super banco vous
avez une éponge p
[Musique]
attention séquence williams que le monde
ait connu non c'est l'avenir du film est
entre autres je pense que les gens si si
vous verrez benitez
quelles que soient les qualités du film
un réseau en avoir attention vous êtes
concentré
2 3 musique
chez blanche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
toutefois lorsqu'il faut me dan hay
répond qu' d'intérêt s'est dit paré pour
le meilleur truc extraordinaire c'est
que tu chantes exactement comme jacques
dutronc fils
[Musique]
ah non c'est bien mais vous n'êtes pas
continuer
[Applaudissements]
il valait mieux dutronc continue sa part
la chanson là alors qui a gagné c'est
noémie bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi je voudrais vous signaler la sortie
d'intérieur surréaliste du décorateur
vincent darré aux éditions rizzoli c'est
un livre dans lequel on retrouve ses
inspirations son univers j'ai failli
l'acheter chez kelly n'y a ni et il me
l'a envoyé merci vincent
[Applaudissements]
tient du génie avec benjamin
changement de nom
[Musique]
merci à lui seul témoin l'a bien c'est
fait
demain 19h au local en bout qui assigne
de l'ardennais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu